Salut ! Cette semaine on est parti pour une série de vidéo un petit peu étrange puisqu'on va parler de Rubik's Cube !
À la fin de ces sept vidéos, vous serez en mesure de réaliser un Rubik's Cube en moins de 2 minutes et avec 5 formules, 5 et demie on va dire... grand maximum !
Et dans cette première vidéo, on va comprendre comment fonctionne un Rubik's Cube.
Qu'est-ce que cet étrange objet ?!
Le Rubik's Cube a été inventé en 1974 par Monsieur Rubik, d'où son nom, c'est donc le cube de monsieur Rubik.
Et dans les années 1980 c'est devenu hyper à la mode, tout le monde en avait un.
Il y en avait des deux sur deux, des trois sur trois, des quatre sur quatre. Nous on va apprendre à résoudre le plus populaire: le 3 sur 3.
Oui parce qu'on dit résoudre un Rubik's Cube !
Donc le Rubik's Cube est composé de 6 faces: la blanche, la verte, la jaune, la bleue, la rouge et la orange.
Lorsque l'on a le Rubik's Cube devant soi, cette partie là c'est la face,
ça c'est le dessus,
le dessous,
la droite,
la gauche,
et l'arrière.
Mais attention ! Car si je me mets dans cette position,
ça, ça devient la face,
le dessus,
le dessous,
la gauche,
la droite,
et l'arrière.
Au niveau de sa structure, parce que le Rubik's Cube a une structure !
Ce n'est pas magique, ça ne tient pas tout seul.
Il y a à l'intérieur un axe à trois branches, et chaque branche finit par une couleur.
Ce sont les éléments centraux du Rubik's Cube, c'est ce qui fait que ces éléments là ne bougeront jamais.
En réalité on va déplacer tout le tour. On ne pourra jamais déplacer les axes centraux, puisque eux sont fixes.
Et après c'est un habile jeu d'équilibre entre les coins, ce qui fait que tout ça, ça tient, et qu'on puisse tout bouger.
C'est ce qui nous donne d'ailleurs l'illusion que le Rubik's Cube est complètement libre !
C'est faux ! Le Rubik's Cube est emprisonné !
Une fois qu'on sait ça, on sait tout ! On sait presque tout...
On saura tout à la fin de la septième vidéo.
Dans cette première vidéo, vous allez comprendre comment résoudre la prémière face.
On mélange, on le casse, dans tous les sens.
Vous le reconnaissez, c'est lui qui vous a fait pleurer, qui vous a fait vous énerver, qui vous a fait le casser.
Voir même décoller les gommettes.
Ne mentez pas je sais que vous avez déjà un jour décoller les gommettes pour les mettre dans le bon sens.
Dans la méthode du Rubik's Cube le plus simple est d'essayer de créer la première face, donc celle qu'on a face à soi.
Tout en respectant la première couronne.
Parce que si la je crée une face avec uniquement les blancs et qu'ici sur la première couronne les couleurs ne sont pas respectées et unies,
alors c'est sûr que je ne pourrai pas le finir.
Première face en respectant la première couronne, après on verra comment faire la deuxième couronne, et après non pas comment faire la troisième d'un coup
mais on placera d'abord les plots centraux, ensuite on placera les coins, on les mettra dans le bon sens, et bref tout ça on verra, c'est très facile.
Je peux vous le garantir, vous allez y arriver, parce qu'on est ensemble, on est une équipe, on a un contrat !
Peut-être que je vais trop loin là dedans...
Je pourrai vous apprendre des formules pour créer la première face, mais d'après moi la première face elle peut se faire en toute logique.
C'est le plus simple, et ça vous aidera à comprendre le Rubik's Cube et à pouvoir anticiper après.
On va se prendre comme point de repère la case blanche avec le "V" ici, comme ça on va savoir où on en est.
Et je vais vous apprendre toutes les logiques possibles, sur les mouvements du Rubik's Cube.
Donc regardons ce Rubik's Cube.
Ici j'ai un blanc/vert.
Un magnifique blanc/vert que j'aimerai placer ici.
Et là déjà vous avez envie de quitter cette vidéo, mais ne le faites pas, vous allez comprendre à quel point c'est simple.
Je vais commencer par l'isoler, celui qui est juste là.
Je vais l'isoler en tournant juste là, sur ma droite.
Celui du bas. Donc le blanc/vert est ici.
Et je veux descendre cette partie là. La partie centrale.
Pour faire comme ça.
Vous n'avez jamais vu quelqu'un prendre un Rubik's Cube et faire ça.
La solution c'est de descendre ces deux blocs là d'un coup.
Et de remonter celui-ci.
Je vous refais voir de plus près.
D'abord je maintien tout le coté gauche,
Pour descendre les deux autres.
Puis je maintien le coté gauche et le central, pour remonter celui de droite.
Ca revient exactement à la même chose que faire ça.
Et une fois que j'ai fait ça, je ramène celui que j'avais mis de coté, ici.
Magie ! Il s'est placé !
Et pour remonter cette arrête comme ça,
et bien je vais faire le chemin inverse de tout à l'heure.
Je bloque celui de gauche et le central, je descends celui de droite,
je bloque que celui de gauche, et je remonte les deux.
Il est en place.
J'en ai donc deux de placés sur ma face.
Maintenant je vais essayer de placer un des deux coins ici pour continuer la face blanche avec la couronne verte.
Donc je vais chercher un coin qui est blanc, vert et autre chose.
Et ici ça tombe bien, j'ai du vert, blanc et rouge.
"Ca tombe bien"... Comme si c'était surprenant de le trouver, c'est pas très grand...
Je vais laisser mon doigt dessus pour que vous puissiez bien suivre.
Ici j'ai le vert, rouge et blanc.
Et je veux le monter soit ici, soit ici.
Déjà je vais tourner cette partie basse, pour que vous puissiez voir ou il est.
Donc le cube qui nous intéresse c'est celui-là.
Il est vert, rouge blanc.
Et on va vouloir le monter quelque part ailleurs.
Ma priorité c'est d'avoir cette face blanche ici, ou ici.
Parce que pour l'instant elle est en dessous, elle n'est pas visible.
Pour faire ça, je vais passer ce cube là, ici.
Maintenant il est en dessous.
Je vais tourner ici de 90° inverse.
Et là, enfin ça devient visible.
Pour que vous compreniez bien ce que j'ai fait, je me remets dans la position d'avant...
Il était ici,
je l'ai déplacé là,
j'ai tourné comme ça...
Et je vais me placer derrière la caméra pour que vous puissiez bien comprendre le mouvement final.
On a toujours notre blanc ici, et notre blanc/vert là.
Et ici notre cube blanc/rouge/vert.
Maintenant je veux que cette face blanche, elle aille ici.
En clair que ce bloc là, remplace celui-ci.
Donc déjà je vais l'amener au bon endroit.
Juste là. Et ce cube là j'ai besoin de le monter là.
Donc pour ça je vais le mettre sur le coté.
Pour le réserver, le protéger ici, juste là.
Je descends l'arrête de gauche.
Je ramène l'arrête du bas, pour le positionner à la place.
Et je remonte l'ensemble.
En clair celui-ci est venu chercher celui que j'avais mis de coté.
Et là, ça commence à prendre forme.
Et je sais maintenant que cette arrête là sera la rouge.
Puisque j'ai commencé aussi ma colonne rouge.
Et ça tombe bien, parce que ici, le rouge/blanc est exactement positionné comme je voudrai mais par contre pas du tout dans le bon sens.
Donc je vais commencé par descendre l'arrête central, avec la même méthode que tout à l'heure.
Je vais le décaler d'un coté, ici.
ça m'a permis d'enlever ce cube là de sa place initiale.
Maintenant je vais le repositionner sous l'arrête qui m'intéresse.
Ici.
Et là je sais déjà que vous vous dites que c'est déjà très compliqué.
En fait ça c'est un cas d'école très très simple.
Il faut dans votre esprit que vous oubliez cette arrête la
et cette arrête la.
Qu'on se concentre uniquement sur celle du centre.
Et si on se concentre sur celle du centre, on voit que lui, il faudrait tourner complètement le cube pour le placer devant.
Et c'est ce que je vais faire.
C'est ce que je vais faire, mais comme je ne veux pas casser mon montage, je descends celui du centre uniquement.
Et là regardez. Il se retrouve derrière l'endroit que je voudrai.
Donc je vais faire 180°, et forcément il se positionne au bon endroit, et je remonte l'ensemble avec la même méthode qu'on a vu depuis le départ.
Et 4 sont placés ! Dont 1 coin.
J'ai vraiment conscience que c'est le plus compliqué de faire la première face.
Je pourrai vous apprendre à faire une croix et avoir des formules pour le résoudre, mais ça me pose deux problèmes:
Le premier c'est que ça vous fait encore des formules à apprendre. Alors que je voudrai que vous en ayez que 5 maximum à retenir.
Et le deuxième c'est que si vous n'utilisez que des formules, vous n'aurez pas la logique du Rubik's Cube.
Autant là ça vous parait peut-être un peu abstrait au départ de faire la première face avec la première couronne.
Autant par la suite ça vous paraitra très simple, vous n'y penserez même plus et vous aurez en tête la logique du Rubik's Cube.
Vous allez pouvoir le décomposer un petit peu mentalement, ça sera plus simple.
Par exemple si je reste dans ma logique, je sais que là c'est vert, là c'est rouge.
Si je cherche un autre cube, où il y a rouge/blanc,
rouge/blanc...rouge/blanc... où es-tu ?
Ici, il y a un cube rouge/blanc/bleu.
Je vois que c'est le bleu qui est associé au dernier rouge/blanc, donc je vais pouvoir en déduire tout de suite que ce sera le bleu ici.
Puisque mon blanc, rouge, sera bleu ici.
Donc je peux m'amuser à l'anticiper puisque je sais déjà que ce sera bleu ici.
Et encore par déduction, je sais que se sera le orange ici.
Un cas particulier pour les cubes centraux, que je vais vous apprendre à résoudre très facilement.
C'est quand un du centre, là le blanc/orange qui va ici,
est sur le coté au lieu d'être sur le bas.
Si on visualise bien, on se dit bien que si on tournait celui-ci comme ça il se mettrai dans la bonne position.
Donc c'est ce qu'on va faire.
On le met dans la bonne position. Et ensuite l'idée c'est de l'isoler du bloc qu'on vient de bouger pour pouvoir remettre le bloc en place
mais garder celui-ci isolé.
Donc je tourne sur le coté.
Et je remonte le bloc tel qu'il était.
Et là mon blanc/orange ne demande qu'à monter, donc je l'isole de ce coté,
je descends l'arrête centrale,
avec la méthode qu'on a vu tout à l'heure,
celui qui était sur le coté, je le place maintenant là où il va.
Je l'ai en quelque sorte "chargé" sur l'arrête.
Arrête que je vient rechercher pour remonter.
Je repasse de l'autre coté de la caméra, pour mettre les trois derniers angles.
Alors ici, il me manque le vert/orange/blanc qui se trouve juste ici.
Je vais vous le positionner du bon coté...
Il est là.
Vert/orange/blanc.
Techniquement il doit prendre cette place là.
Donc je l'isole sur le coté,
je descends l'arrête concernée,
je le charge là où il va,
et je remonte l'arrête concernée.
Ensuite il me manque le orange/bleu/blanc, qui se trouve juste là.
Donc je le positionne pile poil sous l'arrête où j'ai envie de le charger.
Je l'isole.
Je descends l'arrête concernée.
Je le charge.
Et je remonte l'arrête concernée.
Êt le dernier coin bleu/rouge/blanc qui se trouve là...
Encore une fois, je le place sous l'arrête concernée.
Parce que sinon ça n'aurait pas d'intérêt...
Maintenant que je suis sûr de mon coup,
je l'isole.
Je descends l'arrête de droite.
Je la charge du bloc,
et je remonte l'arrête de droite uniquement.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il vient de se passer ?!
On a fait toute notre face, et surtout on a réalisé notre première couronne en même temps.
Je vous ai dit, ce sera surement la vidéo la plus complexe à comprendre et à appliquer.
Faites-le en toute logique. Tâtonnez dessus, cherchez, galérez un petit peu, regardez la vidéo pour voir les cas d'école pour les centraux, pour les coins, pour les mettre dans le bon sens.
Respectez bien la première couronne. Une fois que vous avez fait ça, vous avez fait tout le chemin.
Vous avez fait le plus long !
Et surtout vous avez compris la logique de ce magnifique Rubik's Cube !
Je vais vous laisser 24H pour digérer ça tranquillement.
Une fois que vous avez bien compris et que vous arrivez à le faire de plus en plus facilement, essayez d'accélérer votre temps
de plus en plus, sans aller plus loin.
Toujours juste la face, et la première couronne. Et demain nous allons voir comment faire la deuxième couronne.
A l'aide de deux formules uniquement.
Entrainez vous bien, prenez bien soin de vous, et rendez vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog Spécial Rubik's Cube !
Ciao !